are you coming back to Instagram I just  wanted uppers oh my god I don't know  right now I'm very happy being off  whatever I was saying that it was  because you're being bullied I didn't  know if that was true it was no I think  we're you know I mean there's kind of  like a few reasons why ultimately like  it just wasn't right for right then  yeah and I feel happy being off like I'm  just taking a break before I'm not  working yeah and I never wanted it to do  everything I'm like hey look how great  my life is it's like when I'm working  it's great to be sharing who I'm doing  and a lot of times but this was I got  proper time every before I start working  again for a ban on Murder on the Orient  Express so it's just nice to take a  break take a breather  like I don't accidentally Sharon